aujourd'hui on va parler du wan +7 et
pro je vous ai parlé il ya pas longtemps
ou de ce smartphone là ça c'est le one +
7 tc le tout nouveau smartphone de wayne
plus ce qui est présenté ce qui est
officialisée aujourd'hui même s'ils
étaient présentes et déjà il ya quelques
temps mais dans un autre pays donc n'en
parlons pas aujourd'hui il est
officialisée mais aujourd'hui on parle
pas de celui là on sautera le test dans
quelques jours il ya déjà eu le boxing
pour l'instant on va parler du modèle
pro le modèle pour alors il ya deux
modèles pro cette année il ya le one + 7
pro que j'utilise depuis quelques mois
qui franchement ont déjà bachelot
vachement bien et il ya le one + 7 t pro
qui est une évolution du one + 7 pro
alors il ya moins d'évolution très loin
de plus cette pro et lowell +7 et pro
qu'entre le web + 7 et les one + lt je
sais pas si vous me suivez
ça fait beaucoup de bonnes +7 tout ça
mais en tout cas il est quand même cool
il ya des nouveautés qui sont vraiment
intéressants assez significatif ce que
je vous propose c'est qu'on va se faire
un tour du propriétaire
on va regarder sur votre +7 est pro on a
regardé ce qu'il propose quelles
nouveautés il a qu'est-ce qui peut
vraiment vous apportez escompte euros
pour dire embarque commentaires ce que
vous en pensez
[Musique]
on a donc trois smartphones ici alors je
crois si vous allez voir la différence
ça c'est assez évident on est si lohan
+7 et aux arrivées différences et ses
deux modèles one plus cette probante +7
tpr audit mois lequel est lequel a votre
avis est-ce que celui de droite c'est le
web plus c'est trop beau ne plus s'être
tu es pro et celui de gauche pour ne
plus être propre et 7 pts et pro marquer
ma soeur commentaires dont on n'a pas
beaucoup de temps à les y vous mettez la
porte claque de mets tes commentaires je
compte jusqu'à 3 1 2 et 3 voilà comme ça
vous allez je vais vous donner la
réponse celui là c'est le one + 7 pro
celui assez loin de +7 et pro il ya deux
manières pour les différencier au dos
déjà il ya deux couleurs différentes
sais pas si vous le voyez bien vous avez
deux bleus en fait qu'ils sont
légèrement différents l'idée en fait
c'est qu'il ya pas mal de consommateurs
qui ont dit le one + 7 proxy couleur
bleue elle est très belle mais le
problème c'est que lorsqu'il fait un
petit peu sombre et bien on la voit
beaucoup moins on se rend moins compte
et donner l'impression qu'il est noir
du coup en plus a réagi et a sorti un
modèle bleu est aussi très sympa qui
s'appelle le ix blue et qui est par
contre lui plus clair bleu un peu plus
sur turquoise peut-être mais qu'a priori
on va mieux dans le noir alors j'ai pas
testé j'ai pas être les lumières mais je
pense que c'est possible et surtout le
deuxième point g est vraiment de les
différencier situe au niveau de la
caméra
je pense que la seule à vous sauter aux
yeux c'est ça la la petite caméra tough
qui vient mesurer la distance entre le
smartphone et l'objet que vous avez en
face ce qui permet effectivement bien
deux
d'améliorer les photos au niveau du mode
portrait de faire un focus plus rapide
ça c'est plutôt pas mal sinon vous avez
exactement la même chose qui dit jolie
smartphone dit forcément protection je
vous recommande en tout cas vivement de
venir le protégez vous avez plusieurs
possibilités soit les copains de plus
ceux qui sont très sympas soit l'école
de vos partenaires in aussi que je vous
recommande bien que même aborder des
coques personnalisées
pourquoi pas vous faire une coque
monsieur bré ou une qu'aucun document
alors ça c'est pas la coque de ce
smartphone c'est la coque du one + 6 t
parce que j'ai pas encore reçu les
coques du one + 7 des pros vous pouvez
aussi utiliser les crashs card crash
garde
c'est dur à dire les crashs garde si
vous voulez effectivement profité de ce
joli dos je vous recommande le crash
d'hier comme ça vous pourrez profiter du
dos de votre smartphone
et ça c'est vraiment vraiment cool avoir
été bien évidemment les protections
d'écran pour éviter d'aller leur ailier
ou la ville et les faces avant sont
également sensiblement les mêmes on a
quasiment la même chose on retrouve
toujours l'écran de 6,67 pouces de
diagonale fluide amoled qhd plus 3120
par 1440 pixels à 516 pixels par pouce
toujours un taux de rafraîchissement de
90 heures ce qui marche vachement bien
on a donc exactement le même design
exactement les mêmes boutons ils font
exactement le même poids toujours 206 g
le même capteur d'empreintes digitales
situé sous l'écran qui marche bien
qu'ils rapide qui est vachement efficace
on a exactement les mêmes hauts parleurs
stéréo haut parleurs ici et haut
parleurs qui va se situer ici ce sont
quasiment les mêmes smartphones hp
stéréo dolby et moss il ya quelques
différences mais c'est vrai comme ça le
nu c'est difficile de se rendre compte
pour moi j'utilise morgan mais bon moi
j'utilise à titre personnel depuis
quelques temps c'est vrai que j'aime
beaucoup et va forcer fonctions avancées
sur j'aime beaucoup le one + 7 pro parce
qu'il a effectivement vachement de
qualité déjà il tient bien la batterie
ça c'est vachement cool il est
performant j'ai un certain dragon du 155
sur ce modèle là normalement sans la
lumière c'est vachement mieux il est
performant l'écran est vraiment
d'excellente qualité pour regarder du
contenu surtout vous avez absolument
aucune encoches ça c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment agréable et on
retrouve tout ça en mieux dans le wall
+7 tout tombe on retrouve ça ennuyeux
dans le one + 7 et pro c'est à dire ce
côté très immersif au niveau de l'écran
pour venir regarder du contenu
multimédia c'est vraiment vraiment il
il perd agréable et même pour naviguer
sur internet pour aller regarder d imer
au v6 mais parce que vous voulez pour
aller sur instagram c'est vraiment hyper
cool l'écran est d'excellente qualité
rien pour ça déjà c'est un gros pouce
bleus pour owen plus là dessus
j'avais beaucoup aimé le wall plus cette
pro j'aime beaucoup le voile +7 et pro
après c'est vrai qu'à part l'énorme
différence entre ces deux modèles dont
on pourrait se dire et bien est-ce que
je dois aller sur le wan +7 tpr ou alors
est ce que je veux sur le web + 7 pro je
dirais que la vraie différence va être
un petit peu la balance de prix mais au
delà du prix il ya quand même quelques
différences notables une des premières
différences entre le one + 7 pro et one
piece est des pros ça va être le côté
performance sur le one + 7 pro vous avez
un sens dragon 855 moi j'ai la version
12 giga de ram mais il existe en 6 8 ou
12 giga de ram 128 go de stockage ou 256
go de stockage en urss 3.0 ce qui marche
parfaitement bien sûr la nouvelle
version vous avez un peu moins choix
vous n'avez pas 1,5 dragonne 855 mes
instincts dragon 855 plus qui est plus
performant que le sam rigo 855 vous
n'avez pas le choix entre 6 8 ou 12 il
ya drame vous avez uniquement est ce qui
est déjà très bien
8 gigas de ram et vous n'avez pas le
choix entre 128 ou 256 gigaoctets de
stockage vous avez uniquement est ce qui
est très bien 256 go de stockage ennuis
fs 3.0 alors est ce que ces différences
suffisent justement à faire la
différence pour se dire je vais sur le
modèle 7 et pro ou alors est-ce que
c'est plutôt anecdotique j'aurais
tendance à dire que ça dépend
effectivement de vous et de vos usages
ou déjà vous avez effectivement un
processeur soc qui va être plus
performante mais vous n'avez pas la
possibilité de monter plus haut à g pour
ajouter de la fuite et tous mesure 8
gigas de ram je vous dis on est sur des
smartphones il faut raison garder en
règle générale les usages qu'on va avoir
au delà du côté navigation au delà du
côté séries au delà du côté
divertissement c'est du jeu c'est ce qui
est probablement le plus énergivore voir
si comme vous avez toutes vos
applications ouvertes mais honnêtement 8
gigas de ram avec un sabre à gauche 855
plus ça suffit largement
maintenant si vous vous posez une fois
de plus la question entre le 7 pro et
cette trop pour moi la différence elle
est pas suffisamment importante pour
aller sur le set tu es pro les dites
vous bien que si vous voulez aller sur
le 7 pro avec 12 iliad ram et 256 go de
stockage
je suis pas sûr qu'il n'est normes
différences de tarifs et à ce moment là
il peut y avoir un sens d'aller sur le
site et propos en gros pour la faire
simple en terme de différence en terme
de puissance ça se joue à pas grand
chose
maintenant il ya aussi une différence du
point de vue de la batterie sur le 7 pro
vous avez une batterie de 4000
milliampères heures avec l'avare charge
30 sur le set tu es pro vous avez une
batterie de 4 85 millions terreur avec
la varde charge 30 et lavable h 30 et il
ira loin permettra de recharger plus
rapidement que la femme charge 30
mais dites vous bien que déjà avec la
barbe cherche on agit toujours du mal
avec var charge 36 perdure à dire eh
bien ça change extrêmement rapidement à
votre smartphone vous avez très peu de
temps vous avez un quart d'heure on vous
chargez vous est repartie elle est à 50%
de charge le tout va extrêmement vite on
va encore plus vite avec l'abarth h 30
thé mais une fois de plus ce sont des
écarts millimes même si ça permet
d'aller plus loin et permis d'aller plus
vite
bon pour moi il n'y a pas de différence
notable entre ces deux modèles du poids
du haut touquet de la charge du
président autonomie votre smartphone
vous allez pouvoir garder en une journée
et demie deux jours ça dépend bien
évidemment de vous de ce que vous allez
en faire moi pour vous donner mon
feedback mon vrai retour après plusieurs
mois d'utilisation sur le web + 7 pro ça
smartphones que je regardais allie une
journée et demie un jour un jour et demi
parce que je suis tout le temps dessus
sur les réseaux sociaux je fais des
photos je pose tout temps sur l'écran du
coup je consomme vachement mais le
groupe point positif c'est qu'il se
recharge extrêmement rapidement ça s'est
vraiment bien donc ça dépend une fois de
plus des usages à dépend de vos usages
si vous allez tout le temps dessus ou
pas mais bon voilà pour moi entre les
deux il n'y a pas un monde donc mais ça
c'est pas nouveau one piece nous l'avait
dit lorsqu'on s'est vu et qu'on a parlé
de ses smartphones vous savez on fait un
brief un très brave pour parler des
smartphones et pouvoir me donner toutes
les informations avant de les récupérer
les prendre en main il nous avait dit il
ya plus d'évolution entre le one + 7
éloigne plus sept t4 le one + 7 pro doit
de plus cette tête pro donc c'est vrai
que quand on les compare tout de suite
on se dit ouais ouais ok ils sortent un
nouveau smartphone on se dit que c'est
sortir un nouveau smartphone pour sortir
un nouveau smartphone est ce que c'est
pas un terrain génération et au final
intéressante parce que le one + 7 pro
est déjà super héros en termes de
technologie en termes de performances
tout ce qu'on peut faire avec avec le
one piece 7t pro on va venir un thé peut
peaufiner les détails mais on va pas
apporter quelque chose de petit peu
voire révolutionnaire on a plus cet
effet whaou parce que le modèle qui est
déjà sorti il ya quelques mois est
tellement énorme que vous voyez
forcément on se retrouve avec quelques
points de détail et qui permettent pas
forcément de se dire il faut y aller il
faut des tueurs si effectivement vous
avez besoin de relever votre smartphone
maintenant si tout de suite vous voulez
changer et qu'il vous faut un smartphone
vient le plus haut de gamme de chez vous
n'êtes plus le one + 7 titres on est
juste excellent et là je vous parle
uniquement de performance d'écran
d'autonomie je sais pas encore parlé de
faute à noter que vous n'avez toujours
pas de recharge sans fil ou à ne plus se
positionne toujours pas sur la recharge
sans fil donc vous pouvez pas poser
votre smartphone recharger mais beaucoup
vu l'optimisation qu'on a déjà eu la
rapidité conte avec l avare chartrand
tpi ou la farb change 30 ça marche
parfaitement bien parlons maintenant de
la partie photo alors on change pas une
équipe qui gagne on garde exactement la
même chose à savoir que vous allez avoir
un capteur principal de 48 mégapixels
c'est la fameuse saunier 1586 qui ouvre
à f 1.8 stabilisation optique et
électronique vous avez un grand temps de
l'ultra grand temps de 16 mégapixels qui
est longue de 117 degré qui ouvre à f
2.2 et puis vous avez tel objectif
un zoom optique x 3 8 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.4 avec une stabilisation
optique et cette fois-ci vous allez
avoir une vraie différence ici enfin
vraie différence entre une chance
notable exquis bête en tout cas assez
intéressant même si dans les usages vous
allez voir c'est pas ça qui révolutionne
un petit peu l'histoire c'est cette
petite caméra top ce petit laser qui
veut servir en fait pour mesurer la
profondeur de champ qui l'a calculé en
fait la distance entre le smartphone
l'objet en face ça permettra d'avoir un
meilleur flou au niveau du mode portrait
dont ça c'est bien d'autant plus que
vous avez une amélioration logicielle
êtes vous retrouvé là dessus mais
également bien évidemment là dessus mais
je pense aussi bientôt là dessus je ne
pense pas vous dire bêtise c'est à dire
qu'en fait vous allez pouvoir avoir
différents modes portrait faire un mode
portrait directement avec le
téléobjectif
ou alors avec la caméra principale ça
peut avoir un sens c'est intéressant et
ça je pense que ça va être vraiment
optimisé pour le coup avec ses petites
caméras tough donc ça ça va vraiment
apporter un plus pour avoir des flous
d'arrière-plan toujours mieux détachées
toujours mieux des tours et donc ça
c'est cool pour la hausse est un test
pour voir le focus lequel fait le focus
le plus vite
est-ce qu'il y en a un des deux qui va
falloir qu ce plus vite tout en sachant
que vous
et le roi de +7 et pro qui est juste là
là vous avez le one + 7 pro on va
regarder voyez au niveau des focus je
pose ma main je mets ma tronche j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit complètement
dingue ça me paraît être vraiment un peu
kifkif sensiblement la même chose je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez vous
alors en fait tu sais pas si vous avez
fait guère que le moment je vous dis je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez vous les
chanteurs montage dans c'est pour ça que
je coupe les ailes comme ça on voit
qu'une petite différence que tu ça
devient plus d'être sont loin de plus
cette épreuve c'est vraiment pas grand
chose c'est infinitésimal je passe sur
les roms ça c'est vraiment très très
très court peut-être que ça prend de
l'ordre de quelques millisecondes deux
mois sur le monde plus cet éperon c'est
pas grand chose
je vous mets trop ralenti vous allez
voir c'est quand même assez marrant
parce que vous en pensez vous
[Musique]
par contre vous avez une vraie belle
différence entre ces deux smartphones
c'est au niveau du mode macro alors si
vous aimez la macro il ya un truc qui
fâchent mans coule et que vous retrouvez
également sur le mois le plus sec est à
savoir que sur l' ultra grand-angle et
bien sûr ces deux modèles là vous avez
un petit moteur qui est installée au
niveau lutte racontant qu'il va vous
déplacer la lentille et qui me permettra
d'avoir un vrai mode macro jusqu'à 2,5
cm de distance
l'ag le one + 7 des pros vous voyez une
fois de plus la petite différence ici
lorsque je suis sur ma caméra normale je
vais retrouver ici une petite tulipes je
peux cliquer et là ça me passe ça me va
envoyer sur le mode super macro
positionner le sujet l'histoire de 2,5 à
8 cm en mode macro et quand je suis sur
le smartphone je ne peux pas le faire
est-ce que j'ai pas du tout cette petite
partie en tout cas purement matériels
alors regardez le truc marche vachement
bien
l'ag récupère vraiment les détails au
niveau de la texture au niveau du logo
cheval relief et quand je prends le mois
le plus cette pro et ben je me mets à la
même distance
là par contre c'est tout flou saab au
spa c'est normal c'est la palme bonne
macro intégré mail envoyé par contre
pour le coup on voit absolument rien ça
c'est pour moi une des différences qui
est vraiment intéressante et qui suffit
en tout cas si vous voulez utiliser le
mode macro à justifier l'achat de ce
produit par rapport à l'autre modèle
alors après il faut vraiment avoir
besoin du mode macro si vous n'avez pas
particulièrement besoin
voyez je suis pas sûr que ce soit
vraiment hyper intéressant dans les deux
cas vous avez toujours une caméra de 16
mégapixels ici directement à la vente
ouvre à f 2.0
bon ça marche bien ça c'est sympa c'est
prouvé c'est cool
si vous lâchez la caméra va rentrer pour
éviter de se casser bon ça fonctionne en
réalité il n'ya pas de vraies
différences entre deux côtés le one
piece est pro et le one plus cet éperon
on a exactement la même chose d'un point
de vue hardware on a la même chose d'un
point de vue logiciel la seule
différence que vous allez avoir d'un
point de vue ce petit monde matériel ça
va être cette petite caméra teuf
ça va être d'abord la possibilité
jettera de la macro mais sinon c'est la
même chose
à côté de ça la les photos marche très
bien je ne sais pas si vous avez essayé
le one + 7 pro je peux vous rassurer je
teste depuis longtemps les photos sont
de bonne qualité
au début enfin moi j'avais pas le
problème mais au début c'est vrai que le
la partie software était pas
complètement dingue elle a été optimisée
retravaillé et aujourd'hui vous avez un
truc vraiment sûr maîtriser
la part de wayne puce qui marchent
merveilleusement bien donc si vous
cherchez un bon photophone pour aller
chuté de jour comme de nuit que vous
preniez l'un ou l'autre ça marche
parfaitement bien vous pour elle un peu
plus loin avec le one + 7 des pros mais
ça n'est pas non plus une grosse gifle
après à savoir si vous utilisez souvent
le mode portrait si vous voulez un fou
extrêmement précis j'ai déjà quelque
chose de plus c'est trop ça marche bien
et est ce que vous voulez ce mode macro
voyez maintenant il ya une différence
logiciel entre ici le one + 7 tétreault
et si le one + 7 pro là dans les deux
cas je suis sur la caméra sur le
téléobjectif maintenant sur loing de +7
des pros je peux dire changer leurs
paramètres
ici les attaques et là je change je suis
sur la caméra normale dont il ya quand
même une différence d'un point de vue
purement logicielle entre les deux alors
sur celui là je suis sur oxygen os 10.0
serein android dit cela je suis sur
android 9 sur la version 9 fait calcul
d'oxygène o s donc c'est une partie
logicielle je pense que ça va être
changé plus tard mais normalement ce qui
est sûr c'est que ici avec la caméra
tough déjà vers une meilleure gestion
des fous tout simplement parce que la
caméra vraiment venir à calculer la
distance mois le mur derrière et ça
permettra effectivement sortir la
meilleure optimisation vous avez bien
évidemment toujours du nfc pour le
paiement dématérialisé toujours du
bluetooth 5.0 comme je vous l'avais dit
dès le départ le one plus c'était procès
une belle évolution du won plus c'est
aimer ça change pas bien la donne ça
révolutionne pas bien l'histoire a coûté
ça franchement il est cool alors si vous
devez changer si vous adresse ma seule
qui est un peu anciennes que vous voulez
passer chez what plus regarder la
différence de prix par rapport à la
configuration que vous pourriez prendre
entre le wall plus cette pro et le one +
7 des pros regarder s'il ya une
différence significative en termes de
prix auquel cas s'ils coûtent moins cher
aller sur une puce être pro si il ya un
écart qui minimale et sur le one piece
est des pros il serait quand même un peu
plus puissant vous profiterez des
dernières fonctionnalités des dernières
nouveautés ça c'est assez intéressant si
maintenant l'écart de prix je vous dis
est énorme
allez sur les one + 7 pro c'est un
excellent smartphone et je peux que vous
recommander être très très actuel pour
l'instant en tout cas par contre si vous
avez en plus c'est trop ne cherchez pas
absolument pas aller sur le wan plus
cette épreuve des gens va pas
surconsommer sassard tristement à rien
deuxièmement les modèles sont très très
très proches
en tout cas moi je trouve vous
man cool ce nouveau modèle intéressant
il n'y a pas un pas qui est énorme n'y a
pas d'effet surprise n'y a pas d'effets
whaou avec ce voile +7 et pro s'inscrit
dans la lignée de ce que ces fermes en
plus il est efficace il marche bien il
est cool c'est un excellent smartphone
si cette petite bête vous intéresse vous
pouvez la trouver au tarif de 759 euros
dans une seule configuration 8 gigas de
ram 256 gia de stockage et uniquement
dans cette couleur aussi de changer en
tout cas en france c'est comme ça et pas
autrement et c'est un produit qui sera
mis en vente dès le 17 octobre prochain
à vous de me dire maintenant comment
vous trouvez
est ce que vous le trouver intéressant
ce one + 7 les protège des zones d ombre
à ce qu est ce qui pourrait vous tentez
comment vous le trouvez très clairement
par rapport aux en plus cette prouesse
que vous êtes un peu déçus qui est pas
un écart énorme
est ce qu'au contraire de trouvé ça
intéressant ce que vous aimez ces petits
différence plus de performances un peu
plus loin au niveau de la photo mais une
fois de plus le vent de +7 procès déjà
un excellent smartphone n'y avait pas un
gap énorme affaire affranchir de toute
façon l'année prochaine on aura un one +
8 qui à mon avis lui mettra la barre
encore plus haut je sais pas ce qu'ils
vont nous réserver je sais pas sur quoi
on va aller mais à mon avis ça va être
toute autre chose est vraiment cool est
ce qu'ils vont nous préparer peut-être
une caméra sous l'écran ça pourrait
avoir un sens pour la partie selphy on
verra tout ça à l'année prochaine et
j'imagine plein de nouveautés aussi d'un
point de vue logiciel mais ça c'est le
one + 8 on en parlera en 2020 maintenant
dites moi ce que vous pensez de ce
modèle là on commentaires et puis rester
connecté parce que d'ici quelques jours
on va parler en faire le test du wan
plus ct qui lui par contre marque une
différence par rapport aux mêmes plus
est sur ce je vous embrasse à fellini
gros bisous et je vous dis à demain
ciao